all right what's up game what's up
what's up what's up gamers the first
time i recorded this the audio vanished
it was deleted where i recorded for
about an hour and a half
um reacting to all of your impossibly
horrible opinions your thoughts your
takes on dune you guys sent me some
really weird stuff and i reacted to it
uh in the moment and now i'm going to
have to re-react to it okay it was a
nightmare the first time was a nightmare
to record some of you have some good
takes but the whole point was just to
aggravate me i guess bear with me
catherine said that bull on the wall is
my favorite character i really love the
bull imagery i already feel myself
unraveling white people being able to
handle spice simply isn't believable
fair the scenes in the movie were better
than their book counterparts i what i'm
convinced that george r martin read dune
and based daenerys targaryen's character
off of paula tradies almost 100 percent
certain that that there's influence
there for sure in game of thrones and
just probably in that character so this
is my absolute favorite reply
patrick leo go subscribe to his channel
he has wonderful book reviews but he
said a few people have told me the giant
sand worm looks like an incredibly sharp
and large [ __ ] and i can't seem to
delete this information from my brain no
matter how hard i try help i know
they're going for like the eye imagery
but no it's a butt it's a butt let's see
chris is telling me the baron was better
in the og movie as were the roblox style
shields i i like the roblox shields i
like those something about the new
shields just felt uh
it lacked the spirit of coked up 80s you
know the baron is it's hard for me
because the baron in the
in the 80s movie and the baron now
isn't what i picture of the baron in the
book you know the baron always was just
this cunning
devious
mischievous fellow a jolly old lad
i don't know what his wife said that i
think the first movie should have cut
off after paul and lady jessica escape
into the desert and realize the severity
of what has occurred making the fall of
house of treaties the climax of the film
then made it a trilogy instead of two
parts i hate this i don't don't make it
a tr the trilogy needs to be dune parts
one and two and then dude messiah i have
a video about that go go i'm plugging my
content yeah i don't see how that would
work like what would be the middle movie
for a dune
trill just a plain dune book an
adaptation trilogy i think that would be
it'd be a little too much it'd be too
stretched out i honestly think that the
whole thing should have been put into
like one really long three-hour movie
they'd have to cut out more they then
they do the extended version which is
like five hours you know put that to put
that on the blu-ray ah rhythma says
timothy chalamet is really cute and
handsome
the scene where jessica and paul were
changing was weird as [ __ ] why did they
look
okay that
that's gonna be a running theme you'll
notice in these comments a lot of people
are mentioning this weird
i hate to say it this weird sexual
chemistry between paul and lady jessica
it's his mom
but it's like
especially the scene where they're
changing it's like they're like trying
not to look and like
me and nadia when we watched this we
were like what is going on here it feels
like there's some tension that's like
uncomfortable and i thought that was
just us being weird like picking up on
something like but no apparently a lot
of people are seeing that i'm like what
were they going for some kind of like
oedipus thing like i don't even want to
i don't want to get into that very
confusing movie still don't understand
where it fits into the star wars
storyline getting kind of sick of the
desert planets tbh but maybe still the
best one since the force awakens ha
duncan is a useless character who added
nothing to the story we all know what
was going to happen to him by the end of
the movie haven't read the book yet for
many reasons duncan is not a useless
character especially if you're looking
to the rest of the series no spoilers
foremen are budget ideal yeah that's
gonna annoy a lot of dune fans
i feel weird saying it i thought paul's
dad was pretty hot in the movie so it
was terrible that i read the book and
knew what happened to him i never
thought he was hot while reading the
book why i mean why would you they're
not like and leto walked in the room and
damn
that he had an ass while i really liked
stella and skarsgard that scars sars
guard scars
is it stars guards or skarsgard
but that baron was nothing like the
baron of the books that me that man was
a force to be afraid of and this one was
still holding on to that lynch camp i
like the lynch camp
but
i will say the guy looks a little
strange in all that heavy makeup it just
really looked like he needed to take a
nap like he had just
had really eaten way too much at
thanksgiving so relatable
less scary nobody says out loud but they
have to poop in the still suits so the
fremen are always [ __ ] their pants i
forget is this addressed in the books
because i
this didn't even i just forgot about
pooping it's just all ppp like i just
prioritizing p so what's going on there
with the poop that's something i want to
know the butlerian jihad was not poggers
i second that frank dune is a nice man
these are the these are the type of
comments that resonate the most with me
if you say stuff like this i'll always
i'll always read it it felt like jason
momoa was in a completely different
movie than the rest of the actors i get
why you cast him but his acting style
didn't fit the rest of the cast at all
other than that i loved it can't wait
for the next one fair i mean i'm not a
huge mamoa fan he's not what i pictured
in the books which that's the first
problem you know no one's ever gonna
live up to what you see in the books i
was expecting and really wanting a love
scene between jessica and paul when they
were chilling in the santan after
getting kicked out i need more game of
thrones than my dude
stop no no this this jessica paul thing
it's not a thing just
no i only went to see the original movie
in 1984 because sting was in a bikini i
don't remember much else about it i
don't really care about the new film i
respect that and we should respect that
i don't think the johnny vision scenes
were overused each one was subtly
different and only one match what really
happened in the end great way of showing
multiple possible futures and ties in
with what duncan said about dreams early
on that's a totally you know that's fair
they did show potential futures that's
what i liked about those flash forwards
there are just too many moments of her
walking around in the desert and i think
it was a different actor if it wasn't
just zendaya famous celebrity they could
make it work but because she's like a
huge celebrity it comes across like a
perfume ad duncan idaho is an
unironically great name i hear you i
love duncan idaho earth is this
forgotten planet idaho was this place on
earth somehow through the years it's
become a
a prominent
last name the lack of seeing a space and
guild navigator in the new film was
extremely disappointing we're just kind
of told that spice is important but we
don't really get to see exactly why and
how powerful it can be to be fair i
think that was a good choice because all
we really need to know is that spice
is important the universe needs spice
the focus is on paul and that's what the
filmmakers have said however selfishly i
really wanted to see
a guild navigator i was so excited when
they were going to arrakis i was really
looking forward to oh what are they
going to show and we see them in space
briefly for like a couple shots that
scene in the lynch version version is
just so infamous i feel josh brolin was
terrible and the film doesn't really
give us a good reason uh guardian
docking couldn't have been combined josh
brolin was fine he had such a small part
anyways and like why do they need to
combine them i mean i mean why why why
why why i don't get it that bad tape bad
take a lot of you are coming up with
some popular takes but i'm looking for
the really gross the crusty filthy takes
you know let's go to youtube which i i
have some hope 486 replies let's just
dive in most like comment i don't like
saying it's rough and coarse and it gets
everywhere
overdone meme we've seen it before get
out of my face i'm not hugely fond of
frank herbert's writing style in general
but i love this thing he does where he
drops the word and all the time paul
entered the room looked around left
again it's weird and different and i
love it the rest of the pros not so much
i like the pros i have a video about it
plugging my content the stylistic thing
but it really shows what herbert does
with his writing which is just really
clean it up make it as simple as
possible this one surprised me dune was
published 11 years after fellowship of
the ring i always think lord of the
rings came way before anything you know
but dude is right right up there shows
how insanely influential it is denny
villeneuve did this version as his
second choice since apparently matt
leblanc wasn't available to play all the
roles and how you doon
how you doon i would walk barefoot
across the great flat just for the mere
possibility of trying a drop of lady
jessica's still suit water gross by
essentially eliminating technology dune
becomes a medieval setting this is why
it has aged a great deal better than
foundation which is incredibly clunky
with its out-of-date tech explanations i
don't know why it's aged better i mean
that's a debatable thing we have
things that are so new that they look
like magic
and we have things that are so old that
they feel like
we're stuck in medieval times for fade
ralpha they should get sting and make
him old with cgi for the second movie no
no
no
stop it wait hear me out i don't think
anyone has really addressed this before
but i think maybe the whole dune series
is a metaphor for oil in the middle east
i don't know
dude is really more relevant than ever
and just keeps getting relevant i wish
they had included the dinner scene in
the movie the cloak and dagger of it all
did a lot to aid in the world building i
really love that aspect of of the book
and i wish they had had that in there
but then again you have to ask well what
would they take out to replace it i'm
just wondering why no one was ever
sweaty in the movie it's a dry heat guys
i mean it's a dry heat frank herbert was
a true visionary he wrote dune as a
clear allegory of the mct verse decades
before it was conceived paul is a vivid
representation of joshua i.e the chosen
one while the reverend mother was a
clear embodiment of deborah duncan rick
idaho was always going to be sheltered
by the missionary protectiva given how
cool he is however man carrying thing
harkonnen was born of incest and was
condemned to eternal damnation i
appreciate larry the world building but
you had to make me the baron and i
that hurt my feelings not book related
but if the movies need an old paul kyle
mclaughlin is the one who should be cast
that would be really jarring i think
it'd be too meta freeman demurred way
too easily to paul i love the book but
herbert failed with stillgar's character
when he wrote paul's ascension in the
minds and attitudes of the fremen that
that stillgar was so quickly ditched by
the fremen alludes to him being a
lightweight and i don't think we are
meant to consider him a lightweight his
whole past up to that point is
diminished the freemen are going to
honor the system more than one
person
that's kind of what changes with
when paul enters the cni my suspension
of disbelief was broken when i realized
that in the dune universe humanity gave
up free internet porn in an effort to
stop using computers would never happen
even by the year ten thousand we'd still
keep them around even if they were
trying to actively kill us just to just
to keep that internet porn i think the
dragonfly shaped helicopter planes are
my new favorite thing i lose my [ __ ]
every time i see their little wings
start to flap reading the book i always
thought how would they even show this it
was hard to picture it i love when they
show it just like slowly revving up
gorb said i haven't actually seen her
red dune but i want to participate
anyways so i'm gonna say that dune would
be better if there were more cats in it
hint hint i love you gorb there's a
goblin here enough is a better name than
dune ah
i really really hate that word enot enad
seth rogen would have made an excellent
baron harcon and actually he would he
would laughing
i can't do the laugh but you know that's
kind of how i picture the the baron just
full of this creepy joy i wish i was a
sand worm i wish to wiggle in the sand
excellent thank you i find it really
ironic that dune a book about declining
empire is hitting so big right now in
america and empire
in decline popularity of doom now
instead of in the 80s maybe it doesn't
have anything to do with the quality of
the 80s movie maybe it just has to do
with the times we live in i saw a tweet
not my friend saying there's sexual
tension between paul and his mom again
what is this everyone keeps mentioning
it the true protagonist isn't paul it's
the planet of arrakis i kind of wish the
focus was less on paul than on the other
characters while paul is the main
character he doesn't have a ton of
agency especially in the first half of
the book things just kind of happen to
him so he's not super interesting i wish
he was treated more as an
ensemble and then paul could gain more
prominence in the second movie i haven't
read the book or seen the movie and i'm
not planning on doing so in the near
future i'm planning on reading terry
goodkind before dune this is the type of
thing that'll get someone's blood to
boil i broke my leg today i
i wish you a speedy recovery the whole
movie plot is a meta commentary on
chalamet's career or to be exact how
he's ripping off johnny depp
how is he ripping off johnny depp i'm
genuinely like can someone tell me how
because he's like doing wonka right but
what else i think dune should be made
into a broadway musical would be the
best yes broadway musical dune let's try
it out guys i'd let the baron sit on my
face go for it the part where paul and
jessica change into still suits is
edited in a way that implies they had
sex they didn't go that far like what
are you watching it was just a weird
moment i have neither read nor watched
dude but let me tell you this much the
sand worm just doesn't look like any
human orifice to me the memes are funny
but they ultimately lack the true
comedic accuracy you know have you seen
a human orifice bad guy was just doing a
brando impression oh like marlon brando
i thought you meant like brandon
sanderson
my my first thought was bran brandon
sanderson i just pictured brandon
sanderson playing playing the baron and
i i really like that idea we will have
ornithopters in real life in two to four
decades okay elon musk baron harkonnen
is not evil he's just on that grind set
just that sigma male grind set crazy how
it's actually a ripoff of norm of the
north i noticed that too it was really
upsetting that they stole so much from
norm of the north of all the things to
stand the test of time bagpipes when
they started playing bad bagpipes that
really pulled me out of the movie
characters in the book are not very well
written and that made me not connect
with the story i keep getting comments
like this that are just like well i
didn't like the this in the book i
didn't get into the book or i didn't
like this part of the movie and it's
like yeah they're just opinions like i
don't expect everyone to like the book
or the movie but can't really speak on
that big worm is too scary should have
been a big b or something i barry b
benson rising out of the sand dunes bad
film but the baron was really cute and
sexy really sorry that i just can't get
to so many comments i promise you i read
all of your comments now i've read them
twice has this been useful
i don't know i uh
i have suffered
maybe i'll just end the video like that